hi guys I'm Eric Voss and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 6 swear and I gotta say this
episode actually surprised me a little
granted I know I've done my fair share
of Taran Heath Bashi
where are Heath and Tara oh that's right
no one cares maybe this boat could be
the one that Tara and Heath go out on
into the ocean and then it sinks and no
one misses them or maybe she'll run into
Heath and Tara who are obviously my
favorite characters yeah I know people
weren't crazy about this episode but
Tara actually grew in me a little bit
and I kind of liked how this show
diverged from the comics by introducing
Oceanside this early so in this video
I'm gonna break down all the cool stuff
I noticed in this episode maybe a few
things he didn't notice along with some
theories and predictions for what will
happen when the season hopefully moves
forward with the story at some point so
let's get started with the opening
images so right away we see another
surreal sight for The Walking Dead the
ocean and unlike the West Coast spent
off here The Walking Dead this show has
stayed entirely inland and just like how
episode 3 started off with who's the
boss the image of the open ocean is
another first that catches us off guard
like a lot of people are saying that
this felt like watching an episode of a
completely different show and I think
this image is a big reason why let's
break the shot down so notice how the
Rising Sun reflects off the water a
beacon of light shining through this
frame of rotting roots and driftwood The
Walking Dead is full of visual contrasts
between life and death
but this one is one of the more artful
ones with the promise of something new
beaming through the dead reality that
we're trapped in and I'll talk more
about promises as we go and we meet two
new characters in the scene Cindy and
Rachel members of the Oceanside
community so we'll see that place later
but I was interested in their
conversation here so a stuffed bear has
washed up on the shore and Cindy's
trying to get the younger Rachel excited
about cleaning it up as a toilet ink
keep we can empty it out then you have
an awesome bear alright just like this I
was there else but like most kids who
grew up in the zombie apocalypse
Rachel's having none of that kiddie [ __ ]
she just wants to stab everything in the
face and this bear is a reflection of
Cindy's desire to cling to the humanity
of the pre zombie world and to pass that
humanity on to the next generation
unfortunately this new generation is
growing up bear heap desensitized
they're only interested in survival with
this scary obsession with violence
you're enjoying this
little too much Rachel now in case you
were wondering in real life this
location is driftwood Beach in Jekyll
Island Georgia and I like how as opposed
to like this nice perfect heavenly Beach
all this rotting driftwood and dead tree
roots remind us that we're still part of
this decomposing zombie world in fact
this is actually just like an hour drive
for my hometown in Florida and they're
flesh-eating zombies really do wash up
on the beach all the time it is such a
nuisance ok moving on after the credits
to this scene with Tara and Heath and
right away Tara says this line rule
number one of scavenging there's nothing
left in this world that isn't hidden
now in case you may catch this Tara is
repeating what Glenn told her back in
season 5 this world isn't it so just
like how we saw Enid with her green
balloons everyone is finding weird
sometimes unconscious ways of
memorializing Glenn this show is going
to great lengths to make sure Glenn's
memory lives on now here he brings up
his guilt over what happened in the
satellite station last season and that
is designed to remind us of the incident
so Tara shock at learning how it was
just one of many Savior branches will
pay off later in the episode the guilt
over murdering people will transform
into guilt over starting a war and that
idea of the Savior's being a bigger
threat than initially thought is
reinforced with this shot of Tara's gun
with the image of Lucille branded on the
hill and remember that mark was also on
the gun Karl used last season and at the
time we all just assumed that this could
have been negan's personal gun but what
do you think about it all guns belong to
negan so this mark is on all of their
guns it's literally a brand and it's how
the Savior's know if any of their guns
have been stolen so the bottom line is
even though Tara doesn't realize it the
Savior's are everywhere okay moving on
to Cindy as she looks at this map of
Maryland and Virginia
now we're bigger moves past Alexandria
because she's trying to figure out where
Tara could have washed in from based on
the bodies of water in the area and I
don't think this episode wants us to
think too hard where exactly Oceanside
is in this world considering the nearest
oceanfront beach from Alexandria would
be like across the Chesapeake Bay in
Maryland or Delaware or maybe down south
and Virginia Beach all of which are
multiple days of walking on foot but
again don't think too hard about this
just assume all bodies of water in the
walking dead or connected and that they
all flowed through that magical dumpster
that Glenn hid under now the Roman
numerals on Cindy's clock remind her of
the
Roman numerals on Terra's wrist those
are 26 13 22 and 9 and one more for
character number that ends in an eye now
I'm not sure if this is a tattoo or
something Tara has just like written on
her arm recently but what do you think
these numbers mean some people are
saying that they correspond to letters
of the alphabet z m v and i but whatever
those would stand for
why would Tara have two layers of code
on something that really only she would
ever look at my kind of strips of a
theory is that Tara just like Carol last
season is keeping track of the number of
human deaths that she is responsible for
now I haven't done the exact death
counts but 26 could be the casualties in
the prison battle 13 could be the number
of deaths when they escape terminus and
its people 22 for the deaths since
coming to Alexandria then 9 for the
saviors they killed leading up to the
satellite station attack and then that
last number could be for that battle but
again I'm not at all sure about this and
again I also don't know why she would
use Roman numerals instead of regular
numbers or tally marks so I don't know
maybe those were Tara's favorite super
bowls
now fast-forwarding a bit to our first
real look at Oceanside now I mentioned
this before back when the season tees
list and earlier episodes with Alanna
Masterson boat title slide but we are in
totally new territory here because in
the comics we still haven't seen the
ocean side it's only briefly mentioned
and it's way further along in the
narrative and personally I'm really glad
the show brought in notes inside this
early because even though it seems a
little sudden for all these characters
to look around and stumble into all
these communities after being alone for
six seasons I'm betting the payoff will
be great when all these independent
diverse colonies join forces to
overthrow a brutal regime of the saviors
you'll have Alexandria who's filled with
these crazy murderers along with the
Kingdom who's got some guns and horses
and a freakin Tiger Plus Oceanside with
even more guns and their shoot on sight
policy and the hilltop with um Spears
and a tractor that that's good that's
useful now later on as Tara and Heath
scope out this bridge notice how we see
all these point of view shots peering
out at them from inside the car inside
the RV and the tent and behind the tarp
all these voyeuristic shots do a great
job to raise the tension in the
moment making us feel like there's a
threat hidden somewhere nearby ready to
jump out at them and that is exactly
what happens with this giant sand pile
which is definitely one of the cooler
Walker traps that we've seen on the show
this season now what he seems to abandon
Tara here I think this is meant to
mirror a similar moment in season 5
between another Alexandria Nicholas and
Glenn and Noah in that moment when all
hell broke loose and a parent act of
cowardice by a lesser experienced man
from Alexandria who still prioritize
himself over the group led to a violent
death
Nicholas Slater redeem himself by
sacrificing himself which of course he
does moments later which we see at the
end of this episode so back in the
present time we see more of Oceanside
and this picture on the wall makes it
look like it's a former resort rental
village so just like Alexandria being a
planned community and the hilltop being
this historical tourist mansion in the
kingdom being a former school we get a
little justification for what
Oceanside's purpose was before the
apocalypse began and terra meets the
women in charge netanyahu city's
grandmother along with Kathy and
Beatrice now Tara lies to them that she
used to work on a fishing boat which is
a really dumb lie for a community who
lives on the water and this isn't the
first time that Tara lied about her past
she actually told the governor that she
used to be a cop but notice how when
they asked what type of boat she was on
Tara tells them she was on a larder what
kind of fishing boat did you were gone
trailer santur larder last one you got
it
which we find out later isn't a boat at
all Tara a larder is a room used for
storing meat yeah I was lying now Tara
confusing a place to store meat for a
boat brings up some interesting
parallelism I noticed between this
episode and episode 13 of last season
which was titled the same boat but took
place in a location that was used to
slaughter and store meat both these
episodes show pretty much the same
dilemma both Tara and Cairo come into
contact with female leaders of another
group as they both try to convince their
captors not to kill them by lying about
their pasts these are two lady driven
episodes that go from distress to
negotiation to violence also notice this
line that Netanya says about coastal
areas we're lucky this is a relatively
clear area the evacuations the barges
they were even real so this small line
hints to a lot about the backstory
the idea that people would have flocked
to the coast to get away from land with
the promise of massive boats saving them
from disaster kind of like Noah's Ark
it's also what they do and fear the
walking dead which takes place in
California okay jumping board again a
lot of people were wondering how exactly
Tara knew that these women plan to kill
her there are actually several clues
that Tara picked up on first Netanya was
clearly using coded language when she
invited Tara to come live with them
saying it would be the perfect solution
to our problem as in if you don't choose
to stay here we'll still have a problem
then when Netanya seems too loud Tara to
leave she refuses to allow Cindy to come
to saying I don't want you there
obviously because she's worried cindy
will try to interfere then later when
Tara is about to leave but Tanya says
Cindy is inside sulking that's another
red flag because you think said he would
want to see her off to make sure Tara is
safe but of course Cindy would later end
up being two steps ahead of everyone but
this fist bump failed by the time you
have really signals to tear that
something's off that fist bump is Tara's
move she did it with the governor and
with brick it's a sign of trust and
Janna Tanya's just old and she probably
doesn't understand how this buffs work
but Tara just knows at this point in her
gut that something's up then Tara gets
all these dirty looks from the women of
Oceanside and Rachel even spits at her
so in this moment Tara might just read
this as these people being angry that
they can't shoot her on sight well I'd
be paraded through them like this kind
of looks like she's being led through an
angry mob to the noose to be executed
also quick detail here I like out Tara
flicks Rachel op just like she flicked
off Rick last season
this is Tara's way of saying hey we're
on the same side stop being a dick then
they passed this alarm bell which
Netanya explained earlier that they use
as a way to lure walkers away to a safe
distance but this is also an alarm bell
for Tara warning her that they're far
enough away from the village to not
attract any more danger with gunshots
which is why they had to kill her out
here and not when she was still in
captivity so finally when Beatrice still
seems hostile to Tara by telling her she
was lucky to get the drop on her and
Cathy gives her this murderous look
while holding a knife it all comes
together for Tara oh they don't like
lesbians or more likely they don't trust
her to keep their home a secret now
after the tussle
Beatrice reveals perhaps negan's most
horrific war crime yet that he lined up
all the men in
always over ten in their community and
had each of them shot and even though we
don't see this happen just the specifics
of lining people up and targeting young
boys it definitely echoes things like
the Holocaust and modern war crimes in
places like Sierra Leone but this
inhumanity goes back even further to the
story of Moses in the book of Exodus
when the Pharaoh tried to control the
growing Hebrew slave population by
ordering that every infant boy be
drowned in the Nile and just like those
Hebrews would later do in Egypt this
community staged an exodus of their own
leaving in the night and establishing
this new home which he can only access
by traversing this narrow passage
through a body of water kind of like the
Red Sea now after Cindy saves Tara she
mentions the title this episode you have
to swear hey you'll never come back and
this connects back to that idea of
promises that I mentioned earlier in a
world of fatalistic as The Walking Dead
how much is a promise worth a verbal
agreement that cannot be broken between
two people is one of the last shreds of
humanity in this world and that humanity
is what links Tara and Cindy Tara
believes in the humanity of being
responsible to a group that you're a
part of and Cindy believes in the
humanity of not killing people that you
don't have to now when Cindy says
nobody's evil they just forget who they
are
notice how Tara responds with this line
some people are usual Cindy I've seen it
it's interesting that Tara says this
because she wasn't there for the worst
of what negan and the Savior's have done
to her group she's even no Denise is
dead because she's been gone since the
satellite station attack instead the
evil Terris referring to is the governor
Tara remembers how the governor went
from a seemingly friendly helpful
stranger to this evil psychopath who
murdered Hershel just out of spite and
remembering that people like that exist
combined with this new knowledge that
the satellite station was just one of
many Savior locations brightens Tara
that a new evil could be threatening her
home but Tara is torn between her
humanity to her own people and her
humanity to the person who just risked
her life to save her who's forcing her
to swear to protect her village by
keeping it a secret and that moral
dilemma of which humanity rules out is
what's where is all about I'm pretty
sure it's also what that all for one
song is about
honestly I think everyone would have
been a lot cooler with this episode if
this song was in it okay moving on after
Tara makes it back across the bridge and
we learn in flashback that he actually
didn't abandon her we get this kind of
hokey Walker faked out with Tara
thinking Heath is this zombie black
woman okay not all black walkers look
the same terror come on and even though
this is a little unnecessary for a
second I did think Oh actually I feel
kind of bad that he might be dead so I
don't know how you did it
Walking Dead but you made me care about
teeth and Hara did not think it was
possible but Heath's whereabouts are
still very much a mystery we see his
broken classes and RV left in a hurry
and knowing that Corey Hawkins is
starring on the new show 24 legacy on
Fox I don't know how much longer we'll
see him on this show but what do you
think about this key card that terrifies
with PPP written on it Alanna Masterson
said on the talking dead that the only
person who knows what this means is
showrunner Scott Gimple and no one else
seems to have any clue so very quickly
here are a few theories and morning
they're all kind of stretches so PvP
could refer to another savior location
where he might have been kidnapped and
taken to like maybe the Potomac parking
Plaza or something we know from Daryl's
sweatshirt that the Savior's use letter
based codes for some thing so that's
what this could be or assuming this is
related to the Savior's PPP might be
based on something negan says like pee
pee pants city or pretty pretty please
or piss-poor planning or maybe even
puff-puff pass since we know the
Savior's grew weed in that satellite
location and I think this key card could
be how you get into that room or this
could be musically related like at the
end of sheet music PD P stands for
pianissimo which means extremely quiet
or these might not even be letters these
could be hack notes but to be honest the
only ppb I'm seeing this season is
permanently prolonged pay off now this
montage gives us a couple of interesting
moments like terrifying the boat that we
see in her title slide and picking up
this doctor bobblehead for dr. Denise
whom she doesn't know it's dead and
remember Denise went to the trouble of
getting that Orange Crush for Tara so
these two getting each other these sweet
gifts that neither of them will ever see
is so ironically tragic it's kind of
like that get to the Magi story now
let's talk about the music that plays
over this montage
it sounds Pleasant and reflective but
when you look up what song this is it's
called everything spot by the dirty 3
similarly Tara is relieved to be making
it home but in reality everything is and
that brings us to the closing images
Rosita confronts Tara with this choice
help her community and avenge Denise or
honor her promise to Cindy and keep
Oceanside a secret and it's interesting
how these two options are both literally
in Tara's hands her grief over Denise
symbolized by the doctor figurine and
her swear to Cindy symbolized by Cindy's
shell bracelet and ultimately Tara
decides that for now her humanity rests
with the promise of a new future for
shadowed by the sunrise in the opening
images by upholding her promise to
Oceanside and the stranger who risked so
much just to show her kindness
by the moon and the stars
okay so just one lingering question are
people being too hard on the walking
dead or do you think season seven has
lost its focus a bit ratings have gone
down and I think what viewers are saying
about slow pacing lately
gradually setting up each of these
places without really pushing the main
narrative forward some of that is valid
now obviously I still like the show and
the characters and all the connections
but I'm curious is there a final straw
that you're holding on to still or can
the show do nothing wrong in your eyes
regardless it seems like we won't have
to wait too much longer because the
final two episodes of this half season
look like they'll give us some payoff
next week's episode is called sing me a
song which sounds like a reference to a
really cool moment my comics also a ton
of characters are getting really angsty
and might be on a collision course
people like Michonne Carl Rosita Sasha
can spend sir and I really don't know if
I could stomach if anything happens to
one of them okay that's all I got and
let me know what you think in the
comments and check out my breakdowns of
all the episodes so far this season
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and share this video with your
friends you can also contribute to us on
patreon thanks so much to all of our
current donors especially Kelly hopper
you're the best Kelly if you aren't
currently a patron we'd love your
support you can hit me up on Twitter at
be a boss with any thoughts or questions
or theories that you have about this
season The Walking Dead or you can
follow the new rock stars on Twitter at
new rockstars for information about when
our videos are coming out okay thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you